Speaker 1: Let's hear from people in the
audience. We take calls on the Friday show
via Discord. You can find our discord at
David Pakman dot com slash discord. This is
free. Everyone is welcome to call in. Discord
is free. Calling in is free. It's all free.
I've got nothing to sell you other than
a good time. Let's start today. Wow.
How about Nevin from Tennessee? Nevin, welcome.
Nevin, you're on the air. I heard a noise,
so I know you're unmuted. Welcome. Hey.
Speaker 2: Look, I was just asking about.
Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can, Nevin.
Speaker 2: Okay. Okay. Thank you. So I was just
asking about, do you think it's a good strategy
for Democrats to infiltrate Republican primaries
to try and get the least radical candidate
nominated like the Wyoming one with Liz Cheney? Do
you think we should go into that primary vote and
get Liz Cheney nominated over the other guys?
Speaker 1: Yeah, it's a case by case question
in very so Wyoming being so red, the
winner of that primary will almost
certainly be the not be the winner. So in
that case, I think it makes sense. There
are other races where it's much tighter in terms
of whether a Democrat or a Republican could win
and the efforts would be better served working on
supporting the Democratic candidate. And sometimes
you can have a situation where it's better for
the Republican nominee to be crazier because it
will help the Democrat. Right. So you have to use
your judgment in the Liz Cheney example. It makes
a lot of sense to me.
Speaker 2:
All right. Thank you. That was all I had to ask.
Speaker 1: How are things in Tennessee? Okay.
Speaker 2: It's a deep red
state. So obviously not great.
Speaker 1: So not great. Okay. All
right. Well, keep on keeping on
my friend. All right.
Speaker 2: Thank you.
Speaker 1: Okay. I appreciate the
call. There's Nevin from Tennessee.
It's deep red, so it's not going that
well. You hate to hear that. You really do.